hey jacob
hey
cool so
it's a pleasure to introduce our last
speaker it's uh yaakov
jakob is the co-founder of inceptive
which designs rna molecules for vaccines
and therapeutics using deep learning to
make rna-based medicines more accessible
um and
for those who maybe don't know um jacob
was at google for more than a decade and
he kind of knows a little bit about
transformers
since he was behind the groundbreaking
attention is all you need paper
and so we're really excited to have you
here to tell us what is maybe not so
great about transformers we've heard all
these talks today about how transformers
are like amazing and you know you should
just go use them and have fun and i i
think here we're going to get some kind
of cold water maybe um
so looking forward to it and um
if you want to stream your slides
you don't have slides right you're going
to do it in the background right
awesome so
we'll um we'll be here and i'll probably
jump in at various points when there's
questions please please
thank you for for the introductions and
and um
uh thanks for having me um i should also
add you know um
that paper was actually a really really
fun collaboration with a whole bunch of
people each of whom was absolutely
necessary for for this work to come out
this way um i learned a ton on the way
and i'm incredibly grateful to have had
that opportunity to work with a bunch of
people
um but it is true actually that
um
yeah i'll try to find some cold water um
i think i may have found luke
um i should add as a caveat that this is
not
built like an academic talk
so it's a bit different from from talks
that i gave at conferences
or so in uh that it certainly is full of
bold claims and has absolutely
guaranteed insufficient evidence for
pretty much all of them i think
um
and so you know
believe at your own risk
so so far so good
um you know
people often say if it ain't broke uh
don't fix it i think it's actually an
incredibly useful often very useful
engineering um mantra
but you know there's a there's i think
an alternative uh
sometimes on an alternative mode which
is you know if it ain't broke well let's
try to break it you know let's let's see
what's wrong with it can we find kind of
from first principles uh reasons why
you know something that isn't broken
actually or doesn't seem to be broken
actually is uh is failing in certain
ways um and so maybe the subtitle to
this talk could be something like
three great reasons we should replace
transformer um and you know you would
have never guessed number three um and
so since this is enough uh
or these are were enough attempts at
making jokes even in the first three
four slides the rest of the talk can be
very serious
um
but maybe taking a step back uh you know
let's talk briefly about this kind of
whole premature optimization versus
first principles thinking which i think
is actually uh you know premature
optimization is really what this if it
ain't broke don't fix it tries to
prevent
um and
i think that sometimes this idea of
first principles uh thinking elon musk
talks a lot about it uh on and off um
you know it's potentially kind of a
workaround in a certain sense uh uh
preventing you from um you know doing
optimizations or going into a certain
direction that you that you wouldn't
necessarily
have to go um and so as an early example
i actually remember one one time uh you
know as a preschooler um you know quite
a bit of stuff as a preschooler right
from experience a lot of some not from
experience right but you've probably
learned that moving heavy stuff is hard
and you've also learned the explosions
are really dangerous um and you've
learned that they look like giant
fireballs you know not all of this is
true uh and and generally you know at
least i experience that remote
controlled cars are fast fast and
awesome and then
the first time i kind of you know
somebody tried to explain to me how
combustion engines work
uh there was this hit scratching moment
because what i heard was well you know
cars are generally kind of
built around this giant hunk of metal um
you know and that giant hunk of metal is
really only there because in the middle
they're like small spaces uh in which
they're um explosions
and they're contained by this giant hunk
of very very heavy giant hunk of heavy
metal and and that tries to then channel
all the force of these explosions into
moving you know an even bigger hunk of
metal that is basically uh carrying this
giant type of metal this that is the
engine um and
at least at the time that seemed like a
fairly
backwards way of of doing this obviously
i had no idea about kind of you know the
the
the energy in fossil fuels and all of
that stuff
but it did seem odd um and i think it's
actually not that different
from the thought process that uh
um you know many many years or decades
later uh actually uh
was what started this transformer
project um because you know we did start
with a few kind of first principles
assumptions
namely
maybe most importantly that it is
possible or likely possible
to compute good representations of some
chunks of sequences in parallel
and
what inspired us there most i guess
is really that it seems like
you know those tree structures that
linguists often talk about
when they you know try to formalize kind
of the statistical dependencies between
words and text
are actually kind of often actually kind
of largely right
um so i personally believe they're
almost never exactly right um but but
often you know
largely and what that directly implies
is you know if if indeed those
statistical dependencies um are often
approximately pre-structured then it
should be possible to compute reasonable
representations of you know chunks of
text for sure of sequences of words in
particular um
in parallel before you then you know
uh kind of join these parallel threads
of execution and then uh aggregate uh
you know maybe new more global
representations from that
and
another assumption we made is that
training speed is actually really really
what is most crucial for model uh
quality at the end of the day and that
the key bottleneck at the time at least
was basically
the the longest length of the longest
sequential computation
and so we kind of placed this bet
that parallelization actually
um of these this kind of uh you know
sub-representation computation uh might
be able to buy us much more
than the computational cost
uh that we had to expend in order to
effectively marginalize out the
dependencies meaning basically assume
all dependencies right so
one interesting thing that the
self-attention mechanism employed in
every layer and the transformer does is
it basically actually considers all
pairs of stuff
right and so in a certain sense
you could say it considers all
dependencies all possible dependencies
marginalizes those out
much more expensive
uh
than than say considering only the true
one if there was such a thing and if you
knew it um but
seemingly worth it if as a result of
that you can actually massively paralyze
um
so in my mind at least that that process
was pretty similar uh kind of to to
maybe what made me scratch my head uh
about cars and combustion engines uh
cars with combustion engines uh many
years prior um and and
effectively you know the the the latter
two thirds of the stock i'm going to try
to spend on a few
maybe general areas in which i'm
scratching my head about transformers in
that same way
can i barge in
please
so this is a super nice like historical
kind of uh context about the origin of
the transform architecture and i wonder
if you could expand a bit on the um
the thing about this first principles
approach because
i i would say like at least for myself
it was kind of surprising that
um you could kind of remove the sort of
somehow like temporal nature
which like as as humans when we read
text we tend to read say left to right
or back right to left depending on which
language you speak
and i was just kind of curious like was
this something that you
at google kind of figured out from like
linguists or it's like
it was really like taking a different
perspective on the problem okay so so it
is a it is somewhat different
perspective there was a linguist
involved um
well actually there probably were a few
linguists involved for me personally the
linguist that was involved most was was
my dad uh computational linguist so i
kind of i had no choice
kind of a problem that runs in the
family in a certain sense um and
and so
but but it it wasn't just you know
what i took from him and and
and others wasn't just the fact that
there's maybe this kind of
you know often largely approximately uh
largely approximately right tree
structure but um that in fact
our ways or
this model of thinking of language as
something that is sequential is overly
indexing on our representations of
language and so you know when we
communicate when we talk
we largely say words in sequence except
you know then we
um you know often insert fillers uh and
we also you know often do this and so
forth so we interrupt ourselves the
entire time it's not exactly sequential
right we do jump back yes it's not like
we can just fill in things um but but we
tried uh i think and and
even when reading text in particular we
actually can jump back and i'm not an
expert on on this stuff but as far as i
know it is not true that we always read
in order
so
probably i mean necessarily you can show
we read more in order than not because
we eventually end up at the end of
something right uh
some long string of characters or words
um but
as far as i know humans tend to actually
jump back and forth a lot
um
now that said
yes we could go by the limitations of
our own cognitive apparatus
but
if we have a different one and this
makes a big difference and probably i
should have mentioned this
that actually you know what we were
optimizing for wasn't software that runs
on
some accelerators or some some some
silicon of our choosing it had to run on
these celebrities we had and they looked
you know largely like the ones that we
still have today um except the ones
today are even faster because they're
evolving so fast
but they are just insanely good at doing
these independent simpler uh
computations in parallel and so if you
really wanted to to kind of improve
utilization and what you could squeeze
out
from from these accelerators it just
seemed to be the right direction to
improve paralyzability so that might be
different from how you want to or from
how humans have evolved to process
language um and probably is quite
different uh right um but yeah it's just
different uh
uh hardware or whatever that has
different strengths
awesome thanks for the context and
please play around to tell us all the
problems okay okay
um so
right before i get to all the problems
um
i i did want to say like maybe it's been
like maybe two more minutes or three um
on on you know
why overall
i personally would think it actually
helped um and and really i think the key
thing is this computational efficiency
specifically on today's typical
accelerators um but there's another
reason and that has nothing really to do
with you know the specifics of the model
or the architecture but really that once
in a while
when something different comes along um
it helps with momentum right it helps
with competition you know friendly and
all but but still it really just helps
to
get people to contribute new fresh ideas
or or you know yeah get people excited
about stuff even if initially that
excitement sometimes is disbelief or so
right or uh you know like i said
friendly competition so it was like that
the other way around
um you know
we had um
facebook's convolutional synthesis paper
that uh
uh you know that we in kind of
in our last we thought last stretches of
readying the attention is all you need
uh that we first read it came out then
and that had pretty good results and so
certainly you know that that
nobody knew at the time but that
certainly uh pushed us and motivated us
and so forth and and you know i think
some other things happen afterwards um
in terms of momentum and and fresh ideas
and contributions that got people
excited you know sasha russia this
has this amazing the annotated
transformer post which when i saw it was
just amazing and just really really fun
to see people um
uh do that kind of stuff
and and i think that that actually is
often underestimated as contribution uh
to to you know kind of the community's
reaction is underestimated as a
contribution to um what what kind of you
know
makes this work or made this work in a
certain sense
um okay so nothing else well there's
this one other thing and that's actually
that
decoupling
the architecture and the parameters of
the model from what you could call maybe
the registration of the elements
uh of the structures that the
transformer ingests or or produces
actually allowed a
very easy adaptation to uh to new and
different input and output modalities
different kinds of structures right and
and effectively what it kind of did was
it generalized this this absolutely
revolutionarily powerful seek to seek
approach
to something that's maybe a bit more
like stuff to stuff right so technically
you could say oh it's it's set to
something and then or set to set maybe
even
if you drop a bunch of if you drop
position representations and so forth
but ultimately if you can um
encode the topology if you wish or the
registration of these elements right
these individual positions or
as they were called
initially
that the transformer works on then you
can you can you know apply it fairly
generically not always efficiently but
fairly generically and that in turn
you know made this guy show up um and
and with them you know like this this
horde of other muppets and and you know
uh
friends and and family of
bert uh initially i guess focused on
language really but then uh also
spilling into into vision and into this
really really impressive flurry of
activity around self-supervised uh
pre-training so there was generative
free training which you know also uh
uses the transformer um and maybe in
quotes more traditional way um
uh but exploiting this kind of um
[Music]
flexibility uh you know around the input
and output structures that need not
necessarily just be sequences in that
sense anymore but anything you could
encode in a set somehow um you know just
broadened uh the the or increase the
efficiency of some of these supervised
approaches specifically uh masked uh or
mask style you know denoising auto
encoders and and related approaches
um
and you know this this
has touched a whole range of different
applications uh including now uh
biochemistry so there is now a prop bert
and dna bird and amino bird that you
know play a role in all sorts of
different applications around proteomics
and also provide a great segue for me to
kind of put in a shameless plug
maybe speaking a little bit to to what
to some of the things that we do at
inceptive at least uh which is you know
as as you heard in the introduction
earlier um we're designing uh rna and
specifically initially at least mrna
molecules uh that we try to design such
that they have improved uh
properties in
desired ways such as improved stability
that you might not have to deep freeze
mrna-based therapeutics or vaccines uh
anymore or that they might last much
longer if you do
higher protein expression which could
render more effective and applicable to
a broader range of
diseases and it's just a fascinating
huge search
uh problem with with just ginormous
spaces
even for the coveted mrna vaccines for
instance you have 10 to the 630 synonyms
uh mrna sequences that would actually
produce the same protein uh in our cells
that we want to produce for these
vaccines but it's also an incredible
predictive modeling challenge
right we don't understand most of these
properties meaning we don't understand
how they work
and we don't even understand we don't
even know if we know all the mechanisms
in some cases we know we don't know all
the mechanisms
that kind of give rise to these
properties or the impact them and so we
have very little hope of generating
enough data in our lab for each of these
properties of interest and so really you
know self-supervised pre-training is at
least one of the um one of the pieces of
the puzzle
that we hope to be applying uh in order
to uh you know
tackle tackle problems around uh rna
therapeutics and vaccines
can i barge in again sorry um so this
question you mentioned about like
we don't really understand
the properties of these molecules i mean
wasn't chemistry sort of solved by you
know chemists in some sense like 100
years ago could you maybe sort of expand
a bit on what the challenges are yeah
sure so um
uh i'll try to be quick
because there's still a lot coming but
basically um
kind of true yes uh chemistry kind of
solved but um
[Music]
i would say there are aspects to some of
these macromolecules some of the
biopolymers rna dna um
that are
not exactly kind of small molecule
chemistry in the sense that
you know just like proteins uh they're
their structure their 3d structure their
arrangement in space really makes a
difference
and it can affect uh chemical properties
right so depending on the arrangement on
you know the geometry effectively of of
the bonds relative to each other
you seem to get different uh behavior uh
when it comes to things like hydrolysis
that eventually degrades
these macromolecules for example um but
that's just the chemical side and we're
definitely interested in that but
there's also the
biological side and there it gets even
crazier because you know in in the
environment of cells for example right
there are there is a is an unknown set
of players some of which we know many of
which we don't of of enzymes of proteins
uh
around that effectively have uh highly
non-trivial effects on um uh on the
properties of these molecules like their
biological stability how long they last
in
uh how how much protein they express
and so on and so forth so none of these
properties really are kind of a function
of just the molecule itself
in question but really a function of
any number of different molecules around
which i guess also
explains why you know uh
end to end very large scale uh deep
learning um you know has maybe seems
like a a worthwhile thing to try whether
it's going to work or not for
the specific application of course we
don't know yet um there's some good
indications that it can be useful um you
know as we saw through alpha fold and
i guess some of the proteomics mentioned
models that i mentioned earlier um but
yeah i guess the proof is still in the
pudding awesome
clarification
sure
okay so you know but without back to
these first principles i was uh alluding
to earlier and you know how i personally
think the status quo might actually be
broken right now and the first kind of
cluster of issues that i see uh revolve
around data and this is um maybe also
the most important um given that that
data seems to at the end of the day
always be the one thing you know it's
the one thing that always matters um
it's not always the only thing that
matters uh certainly uh but it
definitely machine learning is the one
thing that always matters
um and i guess i'm in good company with
opinions like this right so thomas uh
tweeted a little while ago a few years
ago i was mostly interested in models um
over time he's seen his interests shift
to data
and you know seems like we're slowly
maturing um i i agree um
i do think it's a bit cyclical um you
know these things go back and forth
when a revolutionary approach comes
along
um and and you know promises and
delivers like learning
uh massive improvements uh then you know
that that becomes for quite a while
tends to become the if it works uh
like it did in the scissors in this case
becomes the
area you know of of
most or a lot of attention uh but then
what we've seen in the field a few times
already is that as uh
the rewards you reap by applying those
methods and improving them uh start to
slowly plateau um
you know you can come back you can
usually come back to data in order to
further improve stuff
um and
one interesting thing that i find odd is
um
that you know we still haven't found
ways of end-to-end learning from samples
from only the input or only the output
distributions so there are these highly
highly effective uh but also pretty
expensive pipeline heuristics i call i
would call them heuristics
like back translation or noisy student
and lots of related methods
that effectively use learn models that
are learned on smaller amounts of
labeled
data and input output pairs um
in order to then
turn either samples from only the input
or samples from only the output
translation distribution
into input output examples and sure you
can do that and it works great um
with some drawbacks but still it doesn't
seem right and there are architectures
in fact
several
one in particular i worked on together
with a bunch of people called kermit
um
that can be trained on um on on input
examples output examples and input up
paired uh labeled examples
but
so far it's not like they've actually
shown even remotely the same kind of
improvement um as as some of these in
quotes heuristics and i find that pretty
odd and you know that's definitely kind
of a
fairly obvious set of scratcher in the
sense that we see this data can help
but end to end and kind of um
yeah
and simplistic or simpler architectures
uh not pipelined uh um schedules or so
forth we haven't been able to really
uh uh you know reach the same
improvements from from from that data
um
a slightly maybe more involved situation
that is also very common actually is
that we're still not able to learn
end-to-end from unaligned data
and so there are many problems out there
where the vast majority of training data
machine translation probably being the
most
the most prominent
where the vast majority of training data
today actually comes from automated was
produced by automated systems that were
given ginormous amounts of input and
output examples but separately input and
output not aligned
but knowing that there should be
alignable uh pairs and and so in machine
translation for instance a work that i
was involved in uh back in 2008 already
um
were recently
far improved uh
stuff um actually a variety of
papers uh have basically proposed these
pipeline systems where you have you have
one step in which you say for instance
mind the web as a collection of
unaligned uh monolingual documents and
you try to identify documents that are
translated or that should be paired a
string data for translation and you do
so oftentimes using a translation system
or something quite similar
um there's also been huge progress in
unsupervised machine translation which
makes this assumption uh right that
those links are not known
but
that's all all of those approaches are
fairly specific uh all the ones i know
of are fairly specific um
to machine translation and and so what i
haven't seen yet and
i'm confused by that is um a generic
approach that applies across mt but also
question answering there should be tons
of questions out there
that
are that also have answers somewhere out
there on the web that should be terrible
um
and
comes with different problems uh but
also shares i think a lot of the a lot
of the problems that machine translation
uh
data infinity automatic um uh has
image descriptions is a similar one
there and maybe see more of a reason for
why we're in that situation right we
we've only recently started to really
use um
you know training on on otherwise
unstructured uh organically created
descriptions or you know of images alt
texts and and similar uh
in a way that really um improves over
over the state of the art trained only
on unlabeled data certainly for image
classification um and and object
detection and friends um but still it
should be possible to to get more data
this way and the list of problems for
which this at least
i think uh
seems to be true
uh is is actually quite long
um
maybe again kind of a
specialization or an extension well an
extension of this could be that it need
not be the case that they come from the
same from the same modality
right so so usually today labeled
examples for one task say translation
for instance right they're specific to
one set or one pair of modalities so
there is now end to end there's
end-to-end speech-to-speech translation
systems and their text-to-text
translation systems uh and so on and so
forth but a translation system that gets
better
if you show it or when you show it pairs
of texts pairs of spoken translated
sentences
pairs of images that depict you know
have half translations in them say for
instance you take a
photo of um
a restaurant menu in one language and
then the translated version
in another language uh where you know
instances or pairs of in all of these
modalities actually improve one at the
same system
and this is despite the fact that
transformers have actually uh helped
along the convergence of architectures
across modalities
and i think one of the reasons why we've
not seen this certainly not much
is that oftentimes these
joining these modalities
in single models is done by effectively
you know adding heads um that are then
specific to those modalities and
unfortunately we haven't yet figured out
um
how to
how to engineer these heads such that
they only take care of things that are
specific to the modality they're
responsible for and not of anything else
and that seems to be
i think a remaining challenge
that could address kind of this
observation that we currently can't seem
to be learning uh well from from
uh examples in different modalities um
or the union of many examples from many
different modalities each
but maybe kind of as an aside to this
how about multiple instances in the
single modality right so instead of
saying
um oh you know we have text text
translation pairs and we have uh
you know spoken uh language spoken
language translation pairs how about
we have for some of those texts
multiple different versions
right so we have maybe multiple ways of
uh
phrasing the same input sentence or the
same output sentence we have multiple
ways of pronouncing a similar input or a
synonymous input or output sentence
how about using that using all of those
in in
together at the same time
there there is some some interesting
evidence from machine translation and
speech recognition actually
that this should help quite a lot
um but if you look at things like uh
computer vision problems where it is
also not uncommon that we have many
images of the same uh
scene or the same object uh there it
seems much less obvious how to actually
then combine those um in in
an elegant way and i think actually
ultimately my intuition would be that it
hints at
an underlying more fundamental
underlying problem that i'll try to kind
of get closer to
later in the talk
um
okay so we're technically already at the
time i wanted to
use initially for for just the
presentation so i'll hurry up a little
bit um and and
you know maybe largely skip over this
part but it is also odd that many
problems uh or for many different tasks
um in computer vision and elsewhere uh
but in computer vision that's
particularly pronounced there they're
probably multiple different uh sources
of data that could be particularly
informative uh for for
learning models for for this task
um and one crass example uh is
you know effectively things like say
object detection where clearly you know
you today most of those models are
trained on um
two-dimensional annotations well maybe
annotations also labels also in three
dimensions but from
annotations of two-dimensional inputs
images uh or sometimes video um
but
you know and plus some semantics but
some labels uh um along with with
bounding boxes
but they don't actually ever consider
um
non-semantic uh
data describing geometry even though
it's actually relatively cheap to obtain
this right so
you know
unlabeled samples of fairly complex 3d
geometries
obtained through lidar
can actually be created at fairly low
costs and i would say intuitively
if if a model that tries to do object
detection understands a ton about not
about semantics of objects in the real
world but about their geometry of common
objects right you know what what do cars
what's the shape cars generally have
what other spices generally have that
that should help but actually so far
that doesn't seem to be something uh
that we certainly not commonly do um and
it also seems like pre-training for this
kind of very orthogonal data that you
want to jointly uh be able to learn from
might not be quite the right parent
um
and so you know maybe to sum up the data
part
there's been amazing progress around
pre-training and fine-tuning and this
general paradigm
but transferring things across
modalities still typically involves what
i would call franklin models so these
are models where basically you know
depending on the modality you turn some
piece on and some other piece off and
you know you you basically swap out
pieces of of the network um more or less
as deterministic functions of the
modality of your input or the modality
of your output and as a result but not
only because of this reason we're far
from able to far from being able to
utilize all the data that intuitively
would seem relevant to a given problem
say like an object detection we're not
utilizing
3d geometry data
and given that data is by far the best
overall i would say a most reliable way
to improve models
that strikes me as a bit as a bit weird
and from first principles i would say
there's a lot of potential for changing
things out
um
we'll get that we'll get back to this at
least a little bit later
but another area is indeed still
efficiency
and you know as i said earlier while
transformers uh improve parallelization
or parallelizability of some of this um
some of the computation of of uh
representations of pieces of your input
or or effectively your output um
and that's that's true and i think
that's that's really the the single
biggest reason uh uh uh why they help in
in many cases um but i actually think
potentially
the biggest head the biggest amount of
the single biggest kind of source of
inefficiency if you wish
still largely remains to be tackled
um
and so you know non-auto regressive
machine translation made a lot of
progress diffusion models have very
recently made really impressive disease
it's actually one of the one of the
really really uh fun things for me to to
you know on occasion uh uh look at back
in like computer vision land or uh
graphics also uh is what people are
doing now with the fusion models i think
it's really really cool addresses some
of the you know aesthetic uh
issues and also practical issues of
other regressive models uh very very
well and in fact if it wasn't for
diffusion models it would have been at
least fourth and maybe a fifth reason
why we should repress transformers um
in this talk uh but yeah then despite
global receptive fields that these
transformers have at least
you know for many modalities
we actually know that the information
stays largely local um so there's a
there's a paper by lenovo and a few
others that look at representations as
they evolve throughout layers and
transformers um and and it seems like
information doesn't travel that far even
though we have this global receptive
field where every piece of your input or
uh representation or your presentation
can talk to any other piece in every
layer and
there's some practical some obvious
reasons for this or more obvious reasons
for this
one is the the omnipresence of residual
connections that provide a very strong
bias
in
for uh keeping representations you know
roughly aligned with the locality or the
registration um
say in sentences the position of a word
that that representation is computed for
but this also means that we allocate our
compute resources
approximately uniform across
this registration across say for example
if you consider images or video
space-time
and okay that doesn't sound like a like
a terrible idea until you look this
image
and if you currently feed this image
into a cnn or a vision transformer it
doesn't matter
most of the flops expended look at blue
sky
and only a small
minority
of them actually look at the bird and
what kind of bird that might be
that seems wrong and seems bad enough
for this image
but if you consider a video with a
non-moving camera
then this is actually true for
most of the pixels most of the time in
most of the videos
approximately this minus some noise
movements and so forth but certainly for
video this seems to be uh you know a
real a real source of inefficiency
and that's simply that the relevant
information for any given task of these
modalities
uh the relevant information content is
often clumpy because that's how the
world is and this is true you know at
fixed resolution fixed sampling rate so
you know fixed
frames per second with a fixed
resolution it's certainly true and
sometimes much worse uh otherwise say
when you have point clouds uh that are
distributed very non-uniformly in in
space in the space time well space
um and there have been some end-to-end
approaches the perceiver is an
interesting is an interesting one but
try to tackle this problem
but so far they don't seem to be
particularly efficient they solve some
of the issues but they don't seem to be
uh
to be a real kind of complete answer to
the efficiency aspect of this problem
and so to me that i can't help it but to
me this smells like compression right
the problem smells like it could be
solved by compression and so we know
that utilizing lossy compression schemes
that are actually aimed at human
perception not machine perception
can help quite dramatically we've known
him for quite a while
and uh so could we just learn
compression schemes suitable across a
variety of tasks and
you know how would they be if at all
different from today's learning
representations that our neural networks
and neural networks evolve kind of layer
by layer
well
one key difference would be that they
should either get faster over time as
training commences
or they should
spread information more uniformly
as
basically as training goes by and as as
the model gets better
and
i think ultimately it in some way
necessitates a change to the way we we
currently train these things uh in part
because we expect the sizes of things to
change right so if we want to get the
speed up then the input size has to
change the input shape can't be constant
um
uh if we want information to spread
more uniformly
uh then again uh
yeah i would i would i would say one can
argue uh that narcan kind of fixed
patching uh um
scheme and so forth paradigm this can't
happen now
as i prepared this talk uh and prepared
the slides and in fact this was this
just happened earlier today um
[Music]
i was looking for one particular
reference uh
that highlighted one aspect of this
problem uh and had to ask alexei
dosovitsky uh
the opportunity to work uh on the vision
transformer and was actually now
inceptive as well i asked him for this
reference and he didn't come back with a
reference he came back with the paper
that hit archive uh on november 3rd that
actually that i hadn't seen um
uh so much for archive sanity or
insanity that actually
for at least
some image tasks uh seems to provide a a
pretty good solution that basically um
you know kind of
uh is along these along these thoughts
and ideas um so so yeah
look for that it's it's it's pretty it's
pretty neat i think um i haven't read it
in detail yet uh but yeah so maybe you
know this is not one of those cases
where uh from first principles it's
still broken as of november 30.
um
okay and so the last one that i'll have
time the last kind of block of things
that i think are broken um
uh revolve around symbols
symbols objects you know this this kind
of stuff and and this is a super complex
topic i'm definitely not going to do any
kind of justice um thankfully there are
some great reviews like the one from
klaus gruff
and and and friends but um
basically the specific kind of uh um
[Music]
potential area and currently active area
of symbolic-ish uh object uh laden
representations uh that i would like to
talk about
shares uh one thing with all the other
kind of instances of objects or
symbolic-ish
techniques in
deep learning
uh namely that my overly simplistic view
of them is that they really are merely
efficiency hacks
that we should learn and that they you
know don't do us any good really
um other than speeding stuff up now this
is definitely a
somewhat controversial opinion um but
if we look at only
symbols in uh and say input and output
representations it's not too difficult
to make that claim at least a little bit
okay so so a thought experiment right
usually we represent text for instance
as a sequence of tokens maybe down to
characters or so right but this actually
comes at a significant cost in
exclusivity
we take this for granted um
but you know
we certainly can currently train text
models that understand this thing
not in full at least right
um
maybe if you were to now kind of add
formatting tags and stuff like that
maybe for this case it were it would
work
and maybe you know you could claim okay
fine but that seems kind of you know
unimportant super rare and whimsical
right but then let me ask you why is it
that i can only have new emojis once a
year
and why do they have to be selected by
some committee right
we recently had this case actually
in practice where you know there's a dna
emoji but there's no rna emoji so we
thought oh can't we make the claim now
that rna is something mrna in particular
that's on everybody's mind can't we just
ask them to get us an rna emoji and we
were about three days too late for the
deadline and uh you know reaching out to
uh to the unicode consortium didn't help
i understand why and so forth but you
know there are definitely some drawbacks
uh to to uh requiring uh um
[Music]
these kinds of
organization um that that's them
ultimately from the fact that we want to
use symbols to encode this stuff
and
it gets pretty bad once you leave kind
of you know the
the latin script dominated
parts and
you encounter that yes in fact there are
scripts to this day where proper type
setting
on computers doesn't really work
mongolian i think is an example that
to be honest i don't know exactly how
common the phenomena are that are not
well expressed uh in in today's type
setting systems um so i can't really
kind of estimate the gravity of these
issues but it's definitely the case that
we're losing out uh in terms of our
richness of representation of things
like text
by using these kinds of symbols so
what if instead of doing that we
presented it you know across many tasks
in a more generic form
say you know as the pixels of an image
into which we've rendered the text and
that's something that we've actually
tried for machine translation um and
uh wrote a little paper about a while
ago um
[Music]
um
but obviously that's terribly
inefficient
right so now instead of using these
symbols that we hand engineer you know
like emojis like unicode at the end of
the day um you know now we have pixels
uh they usually require you you need
many more pixels uh certainly if you
want to express kind of these rich
formatting and graphical phenomena um
and so with today's machinery that's
terribly inefficient
but let's say let's assume for a second
we actually had some
really efficient learned uh and
compressed implicit representation
we could potentially get it down all the
way or not all the way but fairly close
um
to to kind of those symbolic
representations
um and
they might actually remain richer
and it's not entirely clear that we
couldn't in some cases go below that
because text also tends to be
compressible
even even losslessly
and so actually you know it seems like
this idea that effectively seems obvious
for images and video
might even
ultimately help with efficiency if it's
applied to text at least if you have it
in sufficiently large amounts so
to make a very long story and very very
kind of hypothetical story
somewhat shorter i wonder what would
models look like if we
reduce the reliance on external symbolic
representations on hand designed crafted
symbolic representations at least for
input and up
and if we compensated for the efficiency
loss
by generically or with genetically
learned dense implicit representations
and then on the way
increasingly unified use this kind of
transition to increasingly unify the
shapes of different modalities right so
we've not now said that maybe images and
text should or could look very much
alike i don't know exactly what this
would look like i have some some some
guesses but they're definitely too
half-baked to put them even on these
slides um
but you know
maybe we could also apply this to other
to other modalities as well and then
maybe even this
multiple heads input and output heads
hydra problem would go away right could
we then actually just stuff this all
into one single giant neural network not
one where you know individual pieces
have to be turned on or off depending on
what the modality is
at any given moment but where it's
really just the same very dense highly
optimized
architecture same set of parameters you
might not even need elements anymore or
maybe they're always canonical but
they're kind of fixed length up to a
certain degree or fixed size so anyway
i wonder what that would look like and i
actually feel like you know maybe using
at least some of these uh as aspect as
they all are uh observations and you
know quotes first principles had
scratching moments uh to to inspire
thought about um
ideas uh around what those models could
look like
i personally think could be could be
quite interesting
awesome thanks a lot jacob that was
super nice talk
it's um it's not it's not every day that
we get to see the kind of like deep
questions
you know about transformers being
exposed this way so very nice
i think we have time for a couple of
questions
um there's one which is perhaps
a little bit technical but let's see how
we go
so um
it's uh there's a typo but can
transformers be used to find which code
snippets in one language are similar to
another so you know if you've got java
and python and do you think you know
graphical neural networks would be a
solution and i think what this question
is getting at is a little bit this thing
about like you emphasize a lot machine
translation and alignment and this kind
of stuff
and you know do these problems also
occur when we deal with source code
super interesting question um
so let me think basically so i would say
i mean the the the simple
straightforward answer is uh yes um
transformers could definitely be used uh
for for something like this
one interesting question is how would
you define what it means for snippets of
code to be the same um and a very
pragmatic definition that one could
potentially operationalize for creating
uh data around this is to run the code
and see what
happens and if you then you know end up
with either the same result or the same
behavior in quotes then maybe you at
some point if that happens often enough
you want to say yeah these are
reasonably similar
um and in in the process of doing this
basically
instances um uh increasing numbers of
instances and instances of potentially
increasing complexity right if you start
doing this for single instructions and
then you add stuff you might even with
you know fairly unguided search
procedures get to a stage where you can
just create training data for a model uh
that
then might look like something uh like a
seek to seek model but it could also
look like these
i guess what do you call them siamese or
two-tower uh
models that are effectively uh trained
to compare different uh compare
different instances or input
representations um for multiple
instances um
gnns in particular are basically
making use of the fact that that code is
has this has this much more stringent
structure
than uh than natural language or you
know observations of the natural world
around us
i think
i mean certainly in in many cases i
could imagine could help with efficiency
would it dramatically transform our
ability
to identify whether these two things
whether two code snippets are the same
that i'm not so sure about because
ultimately whether they're the same or
not
i guess doesn't have as much to do with
say their abstract syntax trees and how
those relate to each other um
you know where the crispness of genomes
gnns
would help as it does with the semantics
of the code
right the subtle issues are you call two
different library functions they're
defined to be mostly the same except for
some subset of the inputs and
hence you ultimately have to if you want
to do it you know just from from uh with
zero other uh knowledge you basically
have to figure this out
ultimately i guess also
made further problematic because there
are you know many different ways of
computing any one thing and as a result
even going all the way down to executed
instructions on on on a given cpu or so
or given
whatever it is
might
not actually conclusively answer your
question unless they happen to be
acceptance so if they compile to the
same byte code or the same you know
natively execute
instruction sequence sure then then you
can but i don't think that's a
likely event
maybe one more question yeah thanks a
lot one more question would be um you
know in this sort of landscape of of
challenges you mentioned so things with
symbolic representations lossy
compression and so on
which of these do you think is like the
let's say the most important so to speak
if you had to rank somehow these
problems where which ones keep you awake
at night maybe is the other way of
putting it so i actually think they all
uh are
i really think that they all are not
exactly but they all are roughly
different sides of the same coin
so
our difficulties in learning you know
interchangeably from different
modalities you know they stem from the
fact i think
may be overly simplified but i think
they largely stem from the fact that we
have this
this heads problem that basically we we
don't have a neural network into which
we can actually input these efficiently
uh you know
without swapping out some sets of
parameters or maybe some some kind of
structural pieces
and so that you could address by having
a in a certain sense
a representation
at a meta level that is able to express
things in all of these modalities um and
and that you you know you could get
by learning kind of these compression
schemes if you learn them across many
different albums um and
and hence i you know
i guess
i also think that ultimately our our
only way of potentially getting rid of
these symbols which which you know yes i
think they're they currently you know
they are very um pragmatic uh uh
heuristics for for improving efficiency
but we don't know how optimal they are
and they're certainly not sufficient in
order to in order to express everything
we'd like to express but
i would guess they're not
optimally efficient either and there
again i think having these kinds of
uh yeah learned implicit representations
um
is is a reasonably good kind of general
direction for for trying to address
address the potential inefficiencies but
also
kind of broaden their or increase their
expressive increased expressive
explosivity of models for some of these
modalities
and so in a certain sense i think they
all kind of belong to each other um
doesn't mean that the
and it's certainly unlikely that the
easiest or kind of yeah the most um
direct
potential solution for addressing any
single one or any single very specific
subset of these
that they would at all look you know
similar to each other that that i don't
think is the case um
but you know maybe kind of in the limit
if you want to generally solve all of
these it might be that actually
they share uh one at the same solution
so it's a sort of telling us that you
know the future may involve some sort of
you know not maybe radically different
architecture but you know
some that there is life beyond
transformers in some sense i actually
think that the architectures will
increasingly uh get simpler and simpler
and simpler and they will increasingly
look
um
very much
like i mean you'll be able to tell the
architecture from the hardware it runs
on
and so um
ultimately i think to me personally um
the big lesson that i learned
in the vision transformer
work
is that
these patches that we use there
have nothing to do with the images
they they're they're not chosen based on
the image they're they're fixed
so why is it that some patches work
better than other patch
sizes and so forth it's because they
have slightly different computational
tradeoffs
it has nothing to do with the nature of
the images uh as far as i can tell um
maybe in extreme cases that that could
happen you could imagine certain
distributions of images and certain kind
of patch sizes that just
make it harder or make it easier um but
but by and large across kind of the the
universe of images and the universe's
possible patch sizes
or the space of possible quantum sizes
uh what matters i think is how well they
are suited to the underlying harbor and
so
my guess is what we're going to see is
that the architectures will look more
and more boring which i think is great
because architecture engineering tends
to be this kind of
you know black magic alchemy that more
often doesn't work than it does um and
and ultimately i think um
yeah basically we'll use more more
uniform necessarily will necessitate
more and more
similar and uniform
representations
um that have where for instance also the
relation between
representation size if you wish and
compute budget
becomes much much less direct
right so right now if you want to expend
um
more flops on the same image right
take more patches of the same size and
you're going to do exactly that
and and then that doesn't get better
at least from from our experiments that
doesn't seem to get better you know
because somehow your your additional
patches now overlapping or whatever um
add kind of more in a certain sense more
interesting detail it just gets better
because you have more flops
as you would kind of expect but that it
shouldn't it shouldn't be that kind of
your
that your your way of computing your
initial input representation if you want
to think about it that way is kind of
the screw that you use in order to
adjust the expended compute up or down
if anything it should be kind of how
information rich given the task or for
the task a given input
might be and ideally
you know ultimately thinking of us
humans
um a little bit at least
maybe what really should necessitate how
much compute you spend is how much time
you have
if i have a ton of time to compute the
answer for a given input take the time i
mean
assuming the energy comes for free and
in a sustainable manner and so on and so
forth
but but it might not take longer but if
you have to make a decision really
quickly because you know the product
calls for it not in that situation
ideally the model is able to at least
give you a reasonable guess
in much less time with much less compute
and so i feel like that's what we should
actually strive for like anytime
algorithm style
um
anyway so yeah
long story short i think uh
architectures uh will hopefully become
less boring and just ideally suited to
to the hardware they run on and uh
you know in a certain sense the
remaining work to get us there um is i
think in figuring out um how to unify
and uh uh and how to make effective and
efficient
uh the representations that we use
awesome thank you i think we've um run
out of time so thank you once again for
sharing your your deep knowledge with us
and the community and um yeah it's been
it's been a pleasure
hope next time we ask you all these
problems are solved
see i mean given that paper that came
that you know i only just saw earlier
today that came out on november 3rd who
knows yeah
great thank you very much jacob thank
you
thanks